this is grand master daniel nardiski
we're watching the world champion magnus
carlson taking on iranian jim perham
sulu at the 2021 fiji world rapid and
blitz we have a french defense a pretty
rare guest at the highest level and a
pretty risky opening to play against the
world champion magnus oh let's see he
goes e5 and he goes for an advance
that's not the most common response to
the french at the grand master level but
we know that magnus can play anything
and he can play it well queen b6 now
black's idea in this opening is to put
pressure on the d4 pawn that's why
parham puts his queen on v6 and black
can also play a variation where the
bishop comes to b5 i think that's what
he's playing he wants to go bishop d7 to
b5 trade off that bad french bishop and
if black can trade that bishop off and
continue developing then black will
solve his opening problems bishop d3 and
there's bishop b5 by parham now this is
coming at the cost of white's
development and magnus actually takes on
c5 interesting decision there and b4
this is clearly something that both of
these players know black could have
taken the pawn on f2 but then the bishop
would have gotten trapped bishop b3
queen a6 probably still theory now it
looks like a trade is inevitable and
magnus does go for the trade now parham
he's undeveloped all of his pieces so
that's black's biggest problem can
parham develop his kingside pieces
especially quickly or can magnus develop
an initiative as he goes a4 attacking
the queen this is a risky risky line to
play in a blitz game parham he
successfully traded off the french
bishop but now he's got some development
issues that he has to take care of and
first he has to decide where to put his
queen queen d7 is possible he can drop
it back to a6 and keep preventing white
from castling queen c4 is the ambitious
move but then the queen could become
incredibly vulnerable to more attacking
moves like knight a3 or knight d2 so i
think parham has to bring this queen
back this seems to be the first move
where one of the players is out of
theory and it's par hum and that's not
not a very reassuring sign i like
magnus's position i think the d4 square
can also be used as an outpost for
white's knight or white's bishop this
decision to take on c5 it's not very
conventional in the advanced french but
it seems to be a very good one in this
specific variation parham okay there's
the answer queen down to c6 interesting
so now the knight can't come out to c6
but he probably wants to put the b8
knight onto d7 that's the square he
wants to choose for the knights
development now magnus can castle or he
can continue attacking the queen magnus
could go knight d4 in this position and
centralize his knight hit the queen once
again
or he could reserve that move for a
later point let's see what magnus
chooses he's deep in thought
and
looks like he's about to make a move
and he does decide to castle magnus in
blizz still very positional still very
calm takes care of business before he
goes for the attack so he's already
castled white's already got almost
everything developed and finally parham
starts to develop his king side but is
it too late knight d4 by magnus now the
queen has to move again queen back to d7
now the d4 knight could swing over to b5
and try to get to that
very coveted d6 square but black's not
gonna allow that magnus goes pawn b5
restricting the knight on b8 and parham
continues to have trouble developing his
pieces where is that knight on b8 going
to go and parham might have to move his
queen once again in order to make room
for the b8 knight to come out to d7 and
that's exactly what he does he goes
queen c7 but now magnus could try to
prepare the c3 c4 pawn push maybe knight
d2 rook c1 and then very quickly magnus
could try to push c4 and open up the
center before black gets a chance to
castle kingside and that's the question
if parham could rearrange his pieces go
knight g6 bishop d7 and castle black is
going to be more or less out of the
woods but if magnus can open up the
center before black gets a chance to
castle then things are going to look
really grim a knight d2 of course you
can't take that pawn on c3 that opens up
the c file and that is just deadly 97 by
parham he continues to develop as
quickly as he can now will magnus defend
the e5 pawn or is he just going to throw
that pawn to the wolves and instead try
to open up the c file
with c4 let's see what magnus does he
can go pawn f4 to defend the e5 pawn or
he can go rook c1 or maybe even
immediately c4 trying to sacrifice pawns
as many pawns as it takes and boom c4 by
magnus you can see what his mood is in
this game he is trying to explode this
position he doesn't care about pawns and
parham can actually take either the e5
pawn or the c4 pawn he decides to take
the c4 upon a rook c1 looks really
natural here if magnus can get a knight
to c4 man this is looking really really
dangerous this is not the kind of
position you want to have against the
world champion let alone in a blitz game
with where time is so limited and you
have to find precise defensive moves now
parham could take knight takes e5 and
simultaneously defend the c4 square but
then magnus will have bishop f4 pinning
that knight barham goes c3 tries to buy
himself as much time and keep the c file
closed i think he wants to go knight e7
to d5 and continue defending that c pawn
a very flimsy cover
and if the c file opens
it might be really bad and b6 would have
moved by magnus oh my goodness he wants
to go knight b5
what an incredible move and you could
see how surprised parham was b6 vacating
the b5 square for the knight and once he
goes knight b5 as magnus takes the sip
of water you can see how satisfied he is
with his position this is looking really
bad for parham because once he goes
knight b5 not only is he going to be
able to go knight d6 but he's going to
be able to take the pawn on c3 and
accomplish his main target of opening
the c file all of his pieces are going
to be ready to tear black's king apart
and parham hasn't even managed to get
his bishop out of f8 he is nowhere near
castling man oh man this is looking
really bad for black and parham he
continues to think his time continues to
dwindle now he can take the pawn on b6
he probably has to if he takes it with
the queen then he walks into a
discovered attack by the bishop on e3
that's out of the question if you take
with a knight or with the pawn then
magnus goes knight b5 then he takes on
c3 the knight will be threatening to
jump to c7 and d6 there's so many
squares for black to keep track of i
don't see a move for parham i mean he
could move his queen back to c8 he
decides to take on e5 and magnus
immediately jumps out to c4 oh my
goodness now his other knight is in the
game and knight
knight b5 boom now you can't take the
knight on c4 because of the fork on d6
and a queen trade does not held black
because look at how all of white's
pieces will be in perfect attacking
position i think it's going to be
checkmate even after the trade of queens
parham has no choice but to go for it
magnus he could throw a knight c7 check
but i don't think he has to he can play
rook f takes d1 and look how nicely all
of his pieces are positioned but he
takes his time i think magnus is
considering whether to throw in that
check on c7 because at the end of that
variation he's going to be attacking the
rook on a8 and that might force parham
to spend another tempo to move that rook
and magnus goes for a knight c7 check
now he takes the queen to the rook looks
like parham has to move his rook on it
you can't afford to lose an entire rook
here but if he goes rook c8 then this
other knight can jump into d6 and then
there's going to be a fork on the other
square 95 instead by magnus even better
he threatens checkmate on d7 he
threatens knight takes f7 he is tearing
maxoulu apart knight d5 and simply
knight takes d5 he doesn't even need the
rook on h8 he's going down the d-file
barham has to take on d5 now rook takes
d5 and i think the game is over you're
gonna lose the knight on d7 and it's a
mating attack let's see if parham can
find anything to stave off defeat your
bishop a3 you can see his time ticking
down
carlson wins the night his rook on c1 is
hanging parham has that passed pawn on
c3 but it's not going anywhere rook c7
wouldn't move now if there's a trade
then the pawn promotes bc and parham's
losing the c3 pawn he's got to go king
seven and the game is over this is
everything is lost and what an
incredible brilliancy by the world
champion magnus carlson crushing parham
xulu at the world rap and blitz if you
enjoyed this video feel free to click on
the link in the playlist for more of
these videos thank you for watching
[Music]